in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help a semi-aquatic egg-laying
mammal based calculator unravel its
dependency problem and then we do
nothing stay tuned for more I was
grabbing lunch last week with a good
developer friend of mine and the
conversation turned to lamentations
around the limits of google.com as a
calculator I mean frankly it's one of
the more accessible calculators I've
ever used but I end up hitting the
limits of it pretty quickly and won't
even compute the factorial of 256 my
friend then revealed that she created
her own version of google.com calculator
called platy calc however her version
ran on App Engine and evaluated the
submitted math expressions using the
Python runtime which can easily
calculate the factorial of 256 to me
this was immediately brilliant and I
started using platy calc as my primary
web-based calculator however I started
noticing that the first request of the
day was always a little slower than
subsequent requests seeing as I've been
talking about cold boot time a lot
lately I reached out to my friend and
asked to do some profiling on the
application a first look at platy calc
showed pretty much what I was expecting
higher than normal cold boot time now
the code for this app was really simple
I mean there's no global variables no
locking issues and no NDB fetches in the
startup path the only thing that was
occurring globally during boot time was
that it was importing some complex
numerical processing libraries given the
fact that we've already timed a simple
hello world app and seeing what startup
times look like these imports looked
like a culprit just as the test we
removed those imports and re-time to the
startup process just to see if App
Engine cold boot time had suddenly
regressed or if there was some other
issue going on thankfully we weren't
going crazy as our timing showed pretty
much the same startup behavior as I had
seen before at this point process of
elimination was clearly porting to the
imports as the source of the startup
time issues I mean there was nothing
else going on in the app however it felt
wrong to simply discard them outright we
needed more information as such we put
together a small code snippet the timed
how long it took for each of these
imports to occur
our profiling showed us two clear data
points number one the summation of
imports is easily adding about one point
two five seconds to cold boot time for
the application and number two obviously
some of the import
we're taking longer than others now
number two is really the interesting
point here and it's worth taking a
second to discuss see during cold boot
time your application will be busy
scanning and importing code dependencies
the longer it takes to do this the
longer it will take before your first
line of code is executed now some
languages can optimize this process to
be exceptionally fast other languages
may be slower at it but they provide
more flexibility and to be fair most of
the time a standard application
importing a few modules is less than
impactful however when a third-party
library gets big enough we start to see
them do weird things with import
cymatics they can often mess up your
cold boot time a simple google search
revealed that some other developers saw
similar import time issues so it was
clear that this was the problem we were
running into given the fact that imports
were required for our operation our
hands were a bit tied with respect to an
elegant solution nonetheless we came up
with a few ideas to address the issue
number one use a warm-up request when
the website is loading from static
assets send a quick ping to the
calculator service which will import the
required modules rather than waiting for
the calculate button to be pressed
number to lazy load our imports Python
supports this operation by allowing
global versus local importing of modules
so we could move all of the imports to
be function local so if you just want to
do two plus two you don't have to wait
to import the entire side PI module only
when we detect some specific keyword
we'd import those specific things and
number three prune the dependency tree
we've found a lot of Stack Overflow post
and tutorials about how to manually
prune the dependency tree by either
explicitly importing sub portions orbit
or by doing some fun hacks that included
mirroring the module and removing the
things we didn't need but given all that
we decided to do nothing yep platy calc
is not a huge million QPS service it's
just a small application used by a few
friends who really need to compute large
numbers from a command-line interface
for some crazy reason so waiting an
extra second every few days for a query
that wasn't big of a deal in our case we
decided that's the right thing to do
oh by the way if you're looking for what
the factorial of 256 actually is there
you go
thanks buddy calc now as much as I'd
like to beat the performance drum
is that sometimes the result on the
end-user for a particular perf
improvement just isn't justified given
the work needed to fix it so remember
every millisecond counts except in the
few times where it kind of does